i always see you with the mustache at
one point in time yeah you ever have a
beard steve um i never have had a beard
maybe i had a little bit of a goatee you
did have a goatee i thought you were i
had a little goatee that i grew while i
was in a psychiatric ward for three
weeks
you know what i mean
crazy he's an award like a crazy person
the doctors see the goatee they're like
oh he's not getting better that's for
sure i have a psychiatric word i know we
both
dabbled in in some
um
you know crazy behavior and and like
ended up in psychiatric um centers
like even if even briefly did you ever
deal with like a mean like nurse ratchet
type orderly
because i i have i don't remember
that but
i do remember it being pretty scary and
there were certain people in one of the
psych wards i was in who were like just
trapped and couldn't get out yeah what
it's yeah like they'd been there for for
a long time how do you not get out well
because because like you get you're
you're there for a psychiatric
evaluation is what a 5150 is yeah and
you're constantly being evaluated so if
like the the staff of the psychiatric
ward evaluate you and deem you unfit to
be released they just [ __ ] keep you
dude you're at their mercy were you
worried that you were never going to get
out or i was never particularly worried
about not getting out but i was stuck in
there for three weeks you know like the
one time and and and how many of those
psychiatrists wouldn't let me out
how often are you evaluated i mean i
think it's sort of an ongoing thing it's
very pretty damn often right but yeah
there were people who were freaking the
[ __ ] out in my first psych ward
allen watts was talking about a study
they did in the university back in the
day where like they had a bunch of
college students check themselves in to
a psych ward and then try to get out and
then when they got in there they're like
no no this is a school project you don't
understand like we're trying to get out
and they're like sorry
you're in there's some like sadistic
people in in some like people smearing
[ __ ] all over the wall no there's some
people that work there too like are just
i'm not saying everyone but there's some
sadistic people that like i think they
like
the power thing yeah the power thing
like what i noticed one night in miami
you weren't there scott fortunately me
and steve are out on the town yeah this
is a story that we told we did we told
that story fully on the first when you
when you like woke up people didn't see
it you guys partied hard in my head yeah
when i woke up on the car naked but what
so when i was in whatever version of the
hospital like the psycho or the hospital
there was this one like orderly that was
like i was like i gotta get out of here
i gotta go to my hotel i have to present
at the latin music awards and he's like
you're getting a little too excited i
think someone needs a valium and i was
like no just take me back to my hotel
and i'm like yeah oh god it was horrible
like he was freaking the policeman had
to like break it up like okay i'll take
a valium but i really got to get out of
here
i was overwhelmed at that point that's
how that's what got me there
right it was more of a mixture of
cocaine
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and stuff i filmed
for this show is way too hot for jackass
like the general anesthesia bike ride
the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
uh